hello everyone and welcome to game 10 of
the air things masters preliminaries uh
it's basically the second game
of the third day magnus carlson vs
hikaru nakamura the two of the biggest
rivals in modern chess
and it's always uh interesting when when
the two of them have a nice clash so
let's see what happened in this one as
it's uh
it's a very exciting game uh so magnus
uh opens uh with e4
of course with the white pieces we have
e5 by nakamura knight to f3
knight to c6 and bishop to b5 so the
rule offices on the board
and whenever we see this in top tier
games nowadays it's basically always the
berlin defense so knight to f6 we have
castles by magnus and
knight captures on e4 something we see
very often the real gambit we have rook
to e1 attacking the knight and
knight to d6 now attacking the bishop
but not really here just
knight captures on e5 and of course you
cannot trade uh because if you capture
the bishop just knight captures any
c6 check wins the game since you will
lose the queen
whatever you play here so instead we
have bishop to e7 this is all very
standard stuff
and now the knight the bishop really is
under attack so bishop back to f1
and now knight captures on e5 rook
captures and now
nakamura castles and d4
so the rook is uh excellently placed
here on e5 and of course you want to
kick it away from the uh
here uh carlson already had this
position against wesley so this year in
the skilling opened
the game ended in a draw wesley attacked
the rook with bishop to f6
but here nakamura goes for knight the e8
first
he wants to advance the pawn to d5 and
uh he'll kick away the rook from uh e5
later on
so rook back to e1 magnus knows that the
rook will
be attacked so best to move it right
away and now d5
we have bishop to f4 by magnus and now
bishop to d6 so
a very nice uh well sort of a timid
opening choice uh
trading most of the pieces and not
really exposing anything uh to danger so
queen f3
and now bishop captures on f4 and it's
very interesting this position has been
reached before
but the game ended in a draw it was
actually uh reached in
uh creation team championship between
darko felitar and mladen palace the
it was a sort of a team championship and
the day probably was a
draw agreed on all boards so uh the the
game ended in a draw here but of course
uh
the the two of them did not agree to
draw and magnus just recaptures queen
captures on f4
and it is as of move 13 that we have a
completely new game and hikaru
immediately goes queen to d6 the knight
nicely defends it from there
uh so you don't have to ruin your pawn
structure if magnus trades and here
magnus gave it some thought he was like
do i trade queens do i not and in the
end he played queen to f3 he decided
he's not gonna trade queens
and he wants to try and do at least
something with the white pieces not just
draw
after it after two minutes so knight to
f6 preparing bishop to g4
and magnus allows it to just knight the
d2 he doesn't uh
i feel it's necessary to prevent the
bishop from being developed bishop to g4
and now magnus does play queen to g3 uh
queen to b3 might also be an option but
here
magnus decides to trade so queen
captures we have h captures and now
rook f38 hikaru further offers the trade
pieces with
f3 by magnus kicking the bishop back
bishop to d7 and now
g4 always useful when you have doubled
pawns just push one pawn all the way and
you know
good things will happen so here h6 not
allowing uh
to be further pushed with the g5 and now
king to f2
improving the position of the king and
hikaru trades now rook captures rook
captures and
now rook to e8 hikaru offers another
trade of rooks but
magnus again not interested in an early
draw plays rook to c1 he wants to play
c4
and to try and get another line opened
up for his rook
so c6 and now we have a4 by magnus
we broke the e7 and a5 so really
advancing that pawn on the queen side
uh and then now comes knight to e8 the
knight can now come to d6 or c7
uh if needed and now knight to b3 magnus
is also preparing to shift the knight
over to c5 so
knight to d6 the knight will be more
active here also
uh keeping a better eye on that c4
square and knight to c5 magnus now
attacks the b7 pawn as well as the
bishop here so bishop back to c8
guarding the pawn and now b3 not
allowing the knights to jump into the c4
square and also preparing c4 in the
future
so g6 by hikaru and now the immediate c4
so
charging that the d5 pawn he car trades
we have captures captures and
now king to g7 and it's a pretty
equalish position
uh magnus uh magnus's pieces are a bit
more active the a5 pawn is very nicely
placed but
not nothing too serious the situation on
the clock however 15
plus some something seconds uh 15 15
minutes plus some seconds for magnus
so he actually has more time than when
the game started and he called around
10 minutes so here bishop to d3 by
magnus and now
f5 of course uh hikaru wants to
lower the material on the board g
captures on f5 we have bishop captures
and now
again magnus declines the uh
well further trade of pieces by going
bishop back to e2
and now the bishop on f5 isn't really
doing all that much
it was there only to be traded so now
the bishop will probably have to move so
the knight can come to f5
with h5 by hikaru and now knight the d3
asking uh hikaru do you want to trade
bishop for knight but if you trade
bishop for knight
uh with uh play on both sides of the
board maybe the the bishop will be a bit
stronger than the knight so hikaru
doesn't like this he goes back
bishop the c8 you know he frees up the
f5 square for the knight
situation on the clock 13 and a half
minutes magnus uh versus
eight minutes hikaru and here knight to
b4
now you're ready to push maybe a6 maybe
weaken the c6 pawn
and so on so here hikaru goes knight to
f5 puts pressure on the d4 pawn
and magnus just pushes it d5 and with
this move magnus basically creates a
pass
pawn because where you trade the pass
pawn will be created or you play c5
again
d5 will become a past pawn so here
hikaru does go c5 he could also trade
like we said
it also creates a pass pawn but it seems
easier to take care of this pawn
uh instead the hikaru plays c5 uh magnus
goes back knight to d3 and now
rook to c7 he has to defend the c5 pawn
so rook the c7
and now knight to f4 now
uh could be could be dangerous you have
you have to be careful knight to e6
check is lurking for the moment the
bishop is guarding it but
you know you have to be careful so here
uh also you cannot play
g5 as knight captures an h5 would come
with check so here first
h4 this is how hikaru prepares g5 and
now
bishop to d3 we have g5 the knight is
nicely protected by the bishop and
also the knight is attacked and now
while you can go knight stage 5
magnus just brings it back knight to e2
and now comes
knight back to d6 and okay magnus goes
knight
to c3 and still trying to you know
wiggle around trying to wait uh a
mistake from hikaru
and also it's very uh unusual especially
for hikara i mean imagine if you're
hikaru
you are hikaru everyone uh you know uh
no one takes you lightly and
then you face magnus and he he he
doesn't want to give you a draw he he
wants to
really uh play it out uh uh for the
entire game and
try and uh get get a win out of it so
not and not a situation here carl finds
himself in
very often and situation on the clock
eight minutes magnus five minutes for
hikaru
so here king f6 uh of course this this
is the best move hikaru
uh improves the position of his king and
now rook to e1
at some point knight to e4 is coming
magnus wants to improve the pieces uh
his
pieces as best as possible before this
happens
so bishop to d7 a nice waiting move by
hikaru also at some point he's preparing
to push this pawn to b5
and now magnus goes for it 94 check
knight
captures on e4 and now uh it seems like
a good idea to go
f captures on e4 because you have a nice
spawn chain here and if you can get e5
in with
check you're basically winning however
after king e5
you're never getting e5 in the bishop is
now locked in uh
you know behind your light square pawns
so it would actually be black who
who's at least a little bit better here
so instead after knight captures with
bishop captures by magnus and
now comes b5 by hikaru trying to
either get this so he gets a pass pawn
or a capture some b6 alpha song and then
the other one will capture and then the
other pawn will be pushed along the b
file so here magnus goes d6 first as the
bishop covers the light square so the
rook needs to move first
rook the c8 and now c captures and b5
bishop captures on b5 by hikaru and now
rook to b1 and now it's very interesting
what do you do here the bishop is under
attack if the bishop moves you allow
magnus to bring his rook all the way to
b7
and here hikaru has the option of
playing this very safe a6 move
and completely lock off the rook from
using the b file
however after this uh bishop rook to b1
move he cover played bishop to c4
maybe not a mistake in itself but it
allows magnus so much activity
that either by going d7 right away or by
going rook to b7 magnus goes for rook to
b7
he attacks the a7 pawn here and now
hikaru says okay you have that pawn i'm
going to get rid of this pass pawn
so magnus says okay i'm going to capture
this guy because now i get a past a pawn
and hikaru just captures on d6 and here
magnus immediately goes after the c5
pawn
so rook to d to check hikaru tries to
pull a little trick on magnus here
because if magnus isn't careful if he
plays an
active move then rook to e2 is checkmate
you kind of don't want
this to happen so after rook d2 check
magnus has to go back he plays king to
g1
and now uh hikaru took a pretty big
thing
like two and a half minutes which is a
lot since he's very low on time
and he decided to go for bishop to d5
and bishop the d5
simply will not do he should play
something like g4
g4 seems like a a possible move here for
example after pawn captures then you go
back you go after this pawn
and the the game continues however here
he carol played bishop to d5 but this is
just a complete blunder and
it completely blur blunders the game
away so
feel free to pause the video here and
win this game for magnus
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting
the well the rook to d7 move just uh you
know
yeah pinned the attack piece uh and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's
rook to d7 and now this bishop has
nowhere to go if you capture the bishop
then you lose the rook
if you do nothing then you just lose a
piece so he carl played king to e6
attacks and defense but magnus just
moves it back rook to d8 you cannot
defend because
you lose the bishop so here uh hikaru
did the only thing he could he started
pushing his past pawn but carlson's
passport is much
much faster so a6 c3
and the now comes uh well rook captures
on d5
but there's really anything anything you
play here is perfectly fine
because even if bishop captures on d5
it's uh still
just game over this comes with check for
example after king f5 you're going to
play a7
and after c2 you can just put the rook
behind the pass pawn even with this
check for example king h2 or f2 and then
bringing the queen into the game
uh white happily accepts and then brings
the queen into the game of course this
is now completely winning for white
magnus went for a quicker kill he played
rook captures on d5 and it was
immediately in this position that he car
resigned the game
on mu 54 uh because uh well you either
trade and then there is nothing or you
try
something but there is nothing to be
done here for example
if you trade you can get bishop captures
on d5 king captures
and it seems like you will both get a
queen the problem is
magnus brings a queen in with check and
now hikaru cannot bring the queen into
the game
he has to play something anything and
then you just play well whatever let's
say queen a1 you take care of the
queening square
and it's game over so of course hikaru
nudist after rook captures on d5 he
resigned the game and
what a brilliant victory for magnus
carlson taking down his uh
his biggest rival uh but yeah
these are the preliminaries i imagine
both of them will qualify
and they will definitely get a chance to
play each other uh once
one more time in this tournament so we
can expect some more more grinding
but yeah that's uh that's the game i do
hope you guys enjoyed it uh also hope
you enjoyed the thumbnail
really put a lot of thought into that
one
uh i would like to thank lorenzo
rossetti avery brown uh john sved
steven evers uh and john austin for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens
in the chess world so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day